thirty three ways your boyfriend is
micro cheating and totally getting away
with it
[Music]
host what have you been doing what is no
Huffington Post how could you do this I
want to read it
I trust you damn it am i sweating I feel
like I'm sweating a little bit reaching
out to a girl who's just a friend for a
recommendation or advice under me sure
he could easily google the answer to
because he feels like bantering what is
bantering you don't really reach out to
I don't reach out to women
okay so I am fine for now yeah just
thirty two more to go giving a waitress
or a bartender an obscenely large tip
just because she's hot as [ __ ] that's
right I never get to anyone what
let's see Melanie what you got next is
that who wrote it or Oh Melanie Berlin I
think the real title of this shouldn't
really just be 33 ways I am insecure
about my boyfriend and totally getting
away with it following a ton of hot
girls in social media I'm beginning to
feel like he actually knows them because
he monitor is there every post that
closely I mean I already know that you
follow Taylor Swift I don't I uh know
yeah fast oh yeah remember when the they
hacked her and he came out that you guys
were texting on Twitter and then you
were like Martha have to tell you that I
think number four
sending someone who's not his girlfriend
blade something blatantly provocative
like an article about sex or the porn
industry because he thinks she'll find
it interesting or whatever oh yeah who
are you dating Miller yeah exactly
that's the real question here wait this
one is good logging a girl in his
contacts folder under a code name to
avoid detection oh so if you name
someone they're not their name you're
using code to make sure they don't find
out so for example if you had a taste
way that would be a code I wouldn't you
should have really been worried if I did
oh yeah oh my god let me just
double-check on that
tagging another girl in an Instagram
that reminds him of her this is such
subtle things who gives a [ __ ] I mean I
haven't done it but who cares who the
hell cares obsessively checking on the
girls social media feed and getting way
more excited about the non girlfriends
post than he does about confining inner
venting to someone other than his
girlfriend when he's feeling especially
emotional because he craves the response
he thinks he can only get from that what
does that mean and he's like you know
when you ate too much hot sauce yeah you
came home and you were worried that I
was gonna get men oh yeah I was so
scared
I was high from the pain in my body so
maybe if you went another to hearing me
like what can I do to feel better you
said oh asking me you know Melanie
you're damn right about that one you get
that one you should confide in your
girlfriend jump highfive nailed it okay
great
going out of his way to tell a woman he
met or ran into the night before she
looked amazing what first of all how do
you come up with 33 it's so many things
how do you
of all these things she must be really
holding imagine someone like thinking
yes boyfriend JD yeah if it was like a
friend of our like if it's Emily and you
say something nice to them really cool
but I think it's just strange if it's
someone you haven't met and you say that
purposely neglecting to mention his
significant other in conversation with
friends and colleagues he interacts with
regularly so that many of them actually
think he's Melanie you got a point over
here yeah I find it really annoying it's
like dude you're not fooling anyone
I know I know what you're doing I know
what you're doing here and let me tell
you even if you were single no one wants
your ugly ass okay all right diminishing
his relationship is not that serious
when in fact he's cool half cohabiting
and maybe even engaged it's not that
serious
that's what I say to it to my parents
and when we thing we got one
worse yet texting her good morning just
to say good morning Oh
[Music]
have you ever texted anyone good morning
Mike said you were texting anyone good
morning no what the hell you're really
you're reaching for it now like what's
wrong about good morning so nice you
know
I just want to write maybe like Nicola
or my friends and either you that I
don't get to see that often and that's
how you start a conversation yeah
disgusting sending a photo to an ex that
reminds him of a good time past because
he feels like really mean metal so like
if you sign a pic oh whoa no no
following up with a nice to meet you
message oh never say nice to meet you to
anyone disgusting
oh I like these girl he's basically
saying that his boyfriend has to be read
through every girl out there right so he
can I can agree you know I don't want to
completely bash good old Melanie bur
late but I can I can't agree with some
of them you make a list with 33 you got
plenty all right just cut someone out
how about top 10 yeah just go for top 10
next time going out of his way to do
something nice for someone who's not his
girlfriend surveys that you can you
cannot have any friends oh you're not
that's not allowed just treat all women
Bank yeah exactly and he's coming from a
woman and put me put me on the throne
and kiss my ass I do agree with 17
though telling another girl that he's
thinking about her on a day that's not
her birthday is a bit weird yeah if you
were like what does that if you tell
someone so we got to that's micro
cheating Oh 2017 micro cheating Mike if
you get at least 10 10 of 10 of these
you are it turns into cheating that's
why she means in stablishing secret code
words and /or inside jokes with women
outside of
the relationship how dare you have jokes
with other women do you have any inside
jokes without me huh she's cheating on
me with another woman
oh it says Emma you're afraid and I will
run out is it Emma pickles
good that's micro cheating yeah yeah I
know have fun this hey that's my dream
all right wait that's my tears what are
you doing
I had no I would never micro cheetah au
Marzia well I gotta say I think that's a
you know right these dresses I don't
know I think with other girls it's what
you make it you if you are with someone
that does all this [ __ ] and it bothers
you don't write an article about it just
get out of that relationship how about
that who eat Suzanne it's in Swedish you
wrote nice to meet you
[Music]
you